what are the main reasons someone should
make a short film
here's the great thing about short film
making i truly believe everybody should
make a short film if you want to i'm not
going to force you to make a short video
to make a short film but there's nothing
to stop anybody from making a short film
so if you have something you want to say
or make or maybe you just want to
experiment and try to do something
because the experimental is also a
really fabulous category of short films
go for it nobody ever regrets having
made a short film and one of the reasons
is it's not so financially disabling is
making a feature feature you put a lot
of money in a lot of people's
expectations and it really has to
deliver short film short time commitment
to make hopefully very very little money
that you put into it so why not go ahead
and do it so i always encourage people
to make short films i think often you'll
find out festivals the festival people
will tell you too like the people who
have the most fun at film festivals are
the short filmmakers because nothing's
really riding on it you know it's not
like there's a lot of investment you're
just there you've made something you're
proud of and you're like hello world
here i am i'm now a filmmaker and that's
the great thing about shorts too it's
that nice bridge from
i'd love to be a filmmaker to actually
being a filmmaker fastest way to do that
is to make a short film but having said
that i also don't think you should make
it so precious is like i must have the
perfect thing before i can become a
short filmmaker i do think and this is
also what's kind of nice about film
school
you can make a lot of small things to
kind of experiment and do stuff and find
your voice that you don't necessarily
need to show the world right that it
could just be something for you
to experiment and to find what you are
as a filmmaker to exercise your
filmmaking muscles it doesn't have to be
shared with the world so quite often i
teach and a lot of my students want to
immediately put their film out into the
film festival or put it on youtube and
that's permanent you know that sends the
word your name it's now something on
your imdb page is now something that
you're showing people to say this is
represents me as a filmmaker and if it's
not something that really is of quality
yet there's still just a learning
experience because i always say shorts
are a learning experience for everyone
if it is truly a learning experience you
can just say that was it i made it and i
learned a lot from it but now i'm ready
to do my more ready for the world short
film so you know everybody can make a
short film i would always encourage
everyone to make a short film i don't
necessarily encourage everyone that
everything you make is so perfect that
you know your mom's gonna love them all
obviously um and your best friend will
love it and the people who are in it
will love it but doesn't necessarily
mean that the world has to see
everything you've made you should be a
little cautious about what you send out
into the world
well that's a great point how does
someone know though because sometimes we
all think everything we do is amazing or
or we have the flip side of that problem
but yeah that's true some people do at
the flip side but they're super critical
and it's like well how do you know that
it's not great until you actually show
it to people so you know one thing i do
like is doing private screenings where
like you and your friends you can get
like five friends all of whom made
something show it at home people now
have beautiful tvs you know invite
people to your
apartment you know make popcorn have a
private screening like a cast and crew
screening and that's a great way
especially if you show more than one
film
to see how it plays with people people
who are obviously on your side
but if you have a bunch of different
casting crews there are strangers there
who you know aren't related to you and
see how it plays see what people do
people do test screenings and features
all the time so do a test screening of
your short and see what happens
however i will say you know it used to
be in the world of like if you build it
they will come like put it up on youtube
people will discover it and all of a
sudden you'll be on jimmy fallon talking
about your short film that made your
whole difference there's so many things
going up on youtube now there's so many
things that are out there you can't
count on like if you build it they will
come it really has to be um a
concentrated effort to get people to see
your film so
if you're worried about it you know do
that kind of test screening if you are
if you do want to send it out into the
world then you know that's what
festivals are for now some people's
shorts are not festival quality shorts
and i will also say i know so many
filmmakers who like apply to all these
festivals and don't get in don't get in
and they're like my film must really
suck it does it's not getting into
anything and then finally it breaks for
them they get into one film festival and
then they get into another and get into
another so you know number one your film
just might not be a festival kind of
film and that's totally fine but also it
may just be that you know again ten
thousand people made short films that
were submitted to sundance so don't
think that you know
because you're one of the ten thousand
and you're not getting in it's because
you personally suck uh i've been on a
less short film jury juries and you know
at festivals and i always want to tell
people that we're like number like we
gave the big prize to film number a but
film number b we debated forever about
and we all really liked it just didn't
get the prize and you always want to say
i wish the filmmaker knew that you know
how much we loved their film and talked
about their film and even though they
didn't actually get the prize you know
they should be very very proud of that
but you don't hear that all you hear is
film number a1 and i didn't win anything
so you know you could honestly be film
never be where you've got so much
potential it just didn't happen for you
at that time
do you advise filmmakers to make a short
film from their screenplay such as like
filming a sequence from maybe the first
page
so a lot of people do that that they
have a screenplay and there's no like
they can't get people to look at their
screenplay that's like the hardest thing
right to break into hollywood and get
people to look at their screenplay so
people say to them you know well maybe
you should shoot a little bit of the
film
and the screenplay and then people can
see that and see the potential of what
this thing could be
so quite often those are like proof of
concept shorts that you take either a
little scene or you maybe take one of
the characters from it and film
something different with that character
just to show that that character has a
lot of potential and could be
interesting
um the hard part is sometimes those
don't hold up on their own like that
little scene doesn't really work as a
film it works to kind of show what the
screenplay could be but on the other
hand you know you if you want to make
your film for like 100 million dollars
you're not going to be able to invest
that much in a little teeny bit of a
short film so that doesn't give you that
you know grandeur that you would get
when they actually make the feature
um so but it's totally legitimate to
make a proof of concept and then you
send that little you show people that
bit and they say ah now i understand
what the feature could be you know a lot
of features are execution dependent
where people just can't see what it
would potentially be so if you put
together a little something you're like
now you can see what it could
potentially be
so it's worthwhile doing that it doesn't
necessarily mean that's a festival short
it really might be just truly a proof of
concept for that feature uh script and
that's all it is uh conversely a lot of
people have made short films that got a
lot of attention then people like
you know there's a feature in there
and then they've written the feature
around the short film you know so
whiplash is actually one of the most
famous ones that it was a feature script
first he couldn't get the attention for
it so he took an actual scene from it
and it's on the internet i think it's on
the blu-ray of the dvd it's pretty easy
to find um
of that
scene and um he had uh jk simmons as the
music instructor but a different kid not
miles teller as the drummer
um and so he shot an actual scene from
it and that's short film
also called whiplash
got into the sundance film festival won
an award and then everybody's like well
i was like well here's the feature
script
so that gave him a lot of momentum by
having
showing people what it could be
but just to play the devil's advocate
for a moment i think wouldn't there be a
little bit of a danger in just shooting
one page because there wouldn't be an
arc to the story it wasn't just one page
it was one scene so you know yeah
exactly you don't you need to have a
beginning middle and end and that's why
sometimes people don't do something
exactly from the script they take
something out of it and carefully
construct it as a short film and those
are more successful because people have
the experience doing it also people have
done like little trailers so recently
the
fresh prince of bel air tv show got
remade as just bel air and how it
happened was the filmmaker thought oh i
could do this kind of gritty version of
um of the fresh prince of bel air now
and he made like a little trailer for
that just for fun because he thought it
was like a good concept of like let's
show the real fresh prince of bel-air
and based on that they were able to
develop a tv series so it does work
quite often that you can show something
and then people see what it could be and
then bigger pieces happen
actually right now too there's another
there's two films that are out right now
um one film called emergency feature
film on amazon prime that was a short
film that did very well in the festival
circuit and then people said to them
this could be a feature and they're like
yes let's make the feature um and then
marcel the shell with shoes on that's
now a feature film too and that was a
short film originally
do most filmmakers realize their short
film is a calling card or almost an
online resume
see i agree with you that i think that's
short films no matter what are an online
resume and not necessarily a calling
card of what you want to do for the
future but calling part of you as a
filmmaker and that's what they should be
this is your chance to do whatever you
want to do that shows your voice like
this is who i am this is what i want to
do
so i know filmmakers who for example
have made comedy shorts they got a lot
of success and they were able to get an
agent off of it and they got meetings
with people in hollywood and everyone
was like
here's a comedy we'd love you to do and
they're like well really what i want to
do is drama i was like well everybody
got excited because you could show them
your comedy on a similar note i know a
filmmaker who did a short film with a
dog um and it was just happened to be
that there's a dog in the story but then
he got offered all these dog features
and he was like i'm not a dog filmmaker
but that's what people can see they're
like oh he works well with a dog we
happen to have a dog script we're
looking for a dog director
dude here we go so you have to be a
little careful that knowing you know you
if you want to make horror films you
should think about what your future
holds so if you want to make horror
films then you should do a horror short
you know you can do a comedy horror
short or something like that but you
should think about where you want to go
if you want to be a documentary
filmmaker i think doing a narrative
short doesn't really help you in any way
if you want to you know make really
slick kind of things in the future you
should make slick thing as your short
film but it also should reflect who you
are too so like for example you know
yeah if you're a comedian or something
like that you shouldn't nobody's
expecting you to make a drama
you know heart rendering drama film and
then you know
have you say but what i really uh this
is who i really am it's like well no we
always knew you were a comedian this is
weird that you want to do these dramas
so you have to think about who you were
where you're going and make something
that is true
expression of you
so then it's don't necessarily make
something just to get in a festival
try to establish your style and what you
want to do and not just do it for trends
well people always ask for example the
program is at the sundance film festival
it's like what is a sundance short as if
you could do like if you tell me it's a
b and c and i do a b and c then i'll get
into sundance right and they always say
no you know we put together this whole
group of different things to put
together the film festival and so there
is no specific this is what we want so
you can't just say like you know a clown
crazy clown film one last year so if i
do a crazy clown film then i'll win this
year or that's what they love they love
crazy clown films so i'll definitely get
in if that's what i do really what
people are looking for is something
unique and special and moving and
heartfelt and you know audience pleasing
and they want to feel like there's some
talent there and they're going to
nurture this talent and expose this
talent to the world so there isn't like
a formula that can that says this is
what will be successful
and you know some people make a great
short film and then make another
short film and it fails terribly
depending on what you consider failing
um you know it doesn't get reactions
from people or people don't think it's
as good as their first film
then they make a third film and people
are like still not so great or it's
amazing so there's no there's no rules
about what makes a good short film or
what you should make there's no
definition of what's a failure too and
quite often filmmakers will tell you
they had to make certain things before
they were ready to make their next film
so those little bits of what some people
might consider a failure weren't a
failure at all it was a learning step
for them so that they could get up to
the next step so you know that's a great
thing about short films there's no
there's really no failure it's as long
as you're making stuff and you feel like
you got something out of it and it was
worthwhile and you've developed your
muscles as a filmmaker
then you should consider it a success